All right, here's the deal.
We're doin' a prank.
Just Lefkoe and you guys.
So, it is the trade deadline.
We're recording this on Tuesday
and we thought
we'd fire up Photoshop
and convince Simms that Odell
is being traded to the Texans.
I think it's gonna work.
Even better, we're in full
costume because it's Halloween.
Look at this. [Laughing]
- Wow. That is amazing.
- Dangerous.
- How do you feel as a brunette?
- Negative, Ghost Rider.
The pattern is full.
- Ohhh my God. Oh my God.
- What?
- I think you're lying.
No?
- Oh my God.
- Did we say that
yesterday, right?
OBJ was traded to the Texans.
- Oh my gosh.
Are you guys seeing this?
- Wait, what?
- Yeah.
Hang on.
- Bro. Bro.
- We're putting up what we have
on the monitor.
I don't know what
you are seeing.
- Yooo! ProFootballTalk!
Odell!
- Oh, poor Gabe.
Gabe's gonna have
a heart attack.
- Dude.
My Super Bowl pick:
the Texans.
- I love that we said it
on the pod yesterday.
- Holy crap.
- We brought them up, didn't we?
- What did they get for him?
A first and a second.
And Houston will also get a—
only a first and a second.
- All right. That's pretty good.
Well, they had to take
the salary into account.
- Man!
- Dude.
Damn. They might be
my new favorite team.
- Wow.
Do we change the whole show?
- Gosh damn.
What did we talk about
in the opening?
- I don't know.
- Hue.
You know what's crazy?
Is your first guess was right.
- Houston?
- No.
- My first guess of what?
- You know...
This ain't real, bro. You just
got pranked on Halloween.
- Are you f--king kidding me?
- [Gasping]
- You f--king ass----s.
Gabe. Did you know this, Gabe?
- Everybody knew, Chris!
Everybody knew!
- You d--k, Gabe!
- Everybody knew!
- You guys are such—
- How did you do this?!
- Everybody knew!
- Yesss!
I like how you
used ProFootballTalk
to make it real, too.
See, I know Lefkoe, though.
You see that?
He doesn't do this.
I know his tells.
"I have a full house!"
- Still fell for it, though.
Still fell for it, though.
- Damn. I really did.
- Yes!
- Gosh!
I'm gonna put all of you
in headlocks, one by one.
00:02:53,375 --> 00:00:00,000